die europäische union schaut weg statt
die landwirtschaft umwelt und klima
verträglicher zu gestalten ist kommt
klimaschutz kaum die rede und das obwohl
wir gerade mittendrin stecken in einer
arten und klimakrise die wirklich
dramatisch ist und sich immer weiter
zuspitzt eine der hauptursachen die
intensivere landwirtschaft und diese
ignoranz könnte langfristig gesehen
tragische folgen für uns alle haben
klicks und hans im future die gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nicht
losgehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen es sind dramatische
zeiten für die landwirtschaft weltweit
auch hier in deutschland ächzen die
landwirtinnen und landwirte unter dem
klima kühl leiden unter der hitze
die maispflanzen verdorren bevor die
maiskolben überhaupt reif sind und tage
zerstört äpfel und birnen die sich
deswegen nicht verkaufen lassen klar ist
die steigenden temperaturen die dürren
und das gehäufte auftreten von
extremereignissen wie beispielsweise
starkregen führen schon jetzt zu
massiven ernteausfällen die
landwirtschaft leidet also extrem unter
den klimaveränderung nach dem
hitzesommer 2018 bekamen die landwirte
von der bundesregierung sogar
entschädigung in dreistelliger
millionenhöhe
wie soll die landwirtschaft uns unter
solchen widrigen bedingungen ernähren
eine riesige herausforderung denn nach
angaben der welternährungsorganisation
fao muss die nahrungsmittelproduktion
bis zum jahr 2050 sogar noch deutlich
gesteigert werden klar ist die
weltbevölkerung wächst doch die erträge
sinken bedingt durch den klimawandel
ein dilemma das menschenleben kosten
könnte doch die landwirtschaft ist nicht
nur opfer der klimakrise ganz im
gegenteil denn die intensive
landwirtschaft ist ein echter
klimakillern in deutschland lassen sich
etwa zwölf prozent der
treibhausgasemissionen auf die
landwirtschaft zurückführen konkret
handelt es sich zum einen um rund 70
millionen tonnen co2 äquivalente was gut
sieben prozent der
treibhausgasemissionen entspricht das
sind methan emissionen die bei der
nutztierhaltung anfallen methan entsteht
in den mägen von rindern und außerdem
auch bei der lagerung von gülle und mist
zu diesen sieben prozent kommen weitere
vier prozent die durch klimaschädliche
landnutzung
und landnutzungsänderungen entstehen
gemeint sind beispielsweise
trockengelegte moore flächen ehemalige
moorlandschaften werden also
landwirtschaftlich genutzt dabei handelt
es sich bei den mooren um enorm wichtige
kohlenstoffspeicher
hierbei werden also ebenfalls
treibhausgase frei nicht zu vergessen
die düngung mit mineralischen stickstoff
und gülle
dabei wird lachgas freigesetzt erst
anfang des jahres 20 20 hatte ein
norwegisches forschungsteam offenbart
wie sehr lachgas wirklich das klima
belastet demnach verbleibt es nicht nur
120 jahre lang in der atmosphäre sondern
entfaltet es dort sogar einen 300 mal
stärkere wirkung als das treibhausgas
co2
demnach hat der weltklimarat den
einfluss der landwirtschaft auf die
weltweiten lachgasemissionen enorm
unterschätzt der analyse zufolge ist die
konzentration in der atmosphäre von 270
parts per million also teile pro
milliarde in der vorindustriellen zeit
auf 330 parts per million im jahr 2017
angestiegen eine rasante entwicklung
also die dramatisch ist 16,3 millionen
tonnen stickstoff in form von lachgas
wurden im zeitraum zwischen 2000 2015
jährlich als emission registriert von
2010 bis 2015 waren ist sogar 17,9
millionen tonnen pro jahr
laut der fachleute ist dieser trend vor
allem auf die moderne landwirtschaft
zurückzuführen
denn in konventionellen düngern ist
stickstoff das wesentliche chemische
element bei sauerstoffmangel der durch
zersetzungsprozesse im boden entsteht
wandelt sich stickstoff in die
stickstoff um in dieser form kann es
dann aus den böden in die luft
entweichen zudem entsteht lachgas aber
auch in einem anderen bereich der
landwirtschaft und zwar bei der haltung
von nutztieren der klimaexperte foto
nahtlos aus bern empfindet diese
ergebnisse aus norwegen als zitat
beunruhigend expertinnen und experten
sind sich einig dass akuter
handlungsbedarf besteht die lachgas
emissionen müssen dringend verringert
werden doch das ist laut den beiden
deutschen wissenschaftler klaus
butterbach bahl und clemens scherzi tat
eine der größten herausforderungen
unserer zeit wenn nicht zu vergessen sei
dabei dass die weltbevölkerung weiter
wächst und der bedarf an lebensmitteln
somit immer weiter ansteigen wird doch
dabei bleibt es nicht die landwirtschaft
bringt weitere vor
mit sich die das klima direkt belasten
so ist die deutsche landwirtschaft
indirekt auch an waldrodungen weltweit
beteiligt denn es werden so viele tiere
gehalten
das futtermittel importiert werden
müssen gigantische waldflächen unter
anderem in brasilien werden gerodet um
dort soja anzubauen das dann als
futtermittel eingesetzt wird dabei
handelt es sich auch bei diesen
waldflächen und wichtige co2 speicher
laut dem weltklimarat pcc können
weltweit gesehen sogar knapp ein drittel
der gesamten treibhausgasemissionen auf
die landwirtschaft zurückgeführt werden
heißt also im klartext die
landwirtschaft gilt das klima das
umweltbundesamt schreibt zu den
treibhausgasemissionen aus der
landwirtschaft folgendes im jahr 2018
war die deutsche landwirtschaft
insgesamt für 63,6 millionen tonnen
kohlendioxid äquivalente verantwortlich
die emissionen aus der landwirtschaft
haben somit nach den energiebedingten
emissionen aus der stationären und
mobilen verbrennung 82 9 prozent und den
prozess bedingten emissionen der
industrie 7,5 prozent einen
substanziellen anteil an den
treibhausgasemissionen in deutschland
eine studie vom institute for free
culture and trade policy mpp hatte
bereits vor einigen jahren ein
erschreckendes ergebnis offenbar demnach
sind die fünf weltweit größten fleisch
und molkerei konzerne für mehr
treibhausgas emissionen verantwortlich
als einer der größten ölkonzerne dieser
welt in diesem bericht aus dem jahr 2018
heißt es konkret gemeinsam sind die fünf
größten fleisch drei konzerne bereits
heute für mehr treibhausgas emissionen
pro jahr verantwortlich als die
ölkonzerne exxonmobil shell oder bp also
einer von den dreien und für die zukunft
ist keine besserung in sicht im
gegenteil wenn man davon ausgeht dass
die fleischer molkereibranche in den
kommenden jahren weiter wächst steht uns
ein kollaps verformt schon 2050 würde
der bestand 80 prozent des treibhausgas
budgets der erde in anspruch nimmt die
studie nennt in einer liste die co2
verursacher auch beim namen der deutsche
molkereikonzern dmk findet sich auf
platz 21 auf platz 24 ist auch der
fleischkonzern tönnies zu finden
doch die landwirtschaft gilt nicht nur
das klima sondern auch die artenvielfalt
der erde regelmäßig berichten wir an
dieser stelle vom dramatischen in
sekten und vogelsterben weltweit erst
anfang des jahres hatte ein
forschungsteam aus norwegen eine
alarmierende warnung herausgegeben
demnach könnten in knapp 3000 jahren
alle und wirklich alle vogelarten auf
dieser welt komplett ausgestorben sein
dieser studie zufolge verläuft das
dramatische artensterben fünfmal
schneller als man bislang angenommen
hatte im vergleich zum vorjahr schlicht
zeitalter schreitet das aussterben der
tiere sogar achtung 1000 mal schneller
voran
in deutschland sind es vor allem
bestände von vogelarten wie amseln stare
und haussperling die stark zurückgehen
schuld daran ist wohl das massive
insekten sterben das wiederum von uns
menschen verursacht wird auch die extrem
vogel feindliche agrarlandschaft führt
zu großen bestands einbrüchen den tieren
wird so nicht nur der lebensraum sondern
auch die nahrung weg genommen
laut dem forscher sanchez bio bewirkt
vor allem eine bestimmte sache das
aussterben der insekten die hauptursache
für den rückgang ist die intensive
landwirtschaftliche nutzung der
landschaft alle bäume und sträucher die
normalerweise die felder umgeben werden
beseitigt es gibt also nur noch
einfacher kahle felder die mit
synthetischem dünger und pestiziden
behandelt werden vor allem die neuen
insektizide den letzten 20 jahren
entwickelt worden seien besonders
schädlich doch genau diese werden
routinemäßig eingesetzt und verbleiben
dann auch in der umwelt dabei kann man
sogar noch davon ausgehen dass die
verluste sogar noch deutlich größer sind
als die studie ist zeigt denn der
rückgang der vögel hat bereits
jahrzehnte vor solchen daten hebung
begonnen zusammengefasst lässt sich also
festhalten dass die landwirtschaft die
große klima und arten krise
hauptsächlich mit verursacht zudem
gehört die landwirtschaft zu den
grössten opfern des klimawandels und das
könnte in zukunft unser aller leben
bedrohen es ist also höchste zeit etwas
zu tun denn nicht nur unsere ernährung
sondern auch unsere gesundheit und der
wirtschaftliche wohlstand hängen von
einer intakten und artenreiche natur ab
bestäubung schädlingsbekämpfung oder
bodenschutz all das sind leistungen die
uns nur eine biologische vielfalt
beschert doch die art und weise wie wir
derzeit nahrungsmittel produzieren macht
die klimakrise nur noch größer wie also
können wir die landwirtschaft umwelt
verträglicher und klimaneutral gestalten
um jetzt die weichen für die zukunft
zu legen wäre jetzt der perfekte
zeitpunkt denn in diesen monaten
entscheidet die europäische union über
die agrarpolitik der kommenden jahre die
rede ist von der reform der gemeinsamen
agrarpolitik gap abgekürzt eine
überarbeitung findet nur alle sieben
jahre statt und unter deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft soll eine
entscheidung bis zum ende des jahres
fallen wir befinden uns also in der
finalen phase die pläne der eu staaten
sehen vor achtung ganze 387 milliarden
euro bis zum jahr 2027 bereitzustellen
um die landwirtschaft zu fördern das
muss man sich mal vorstellen
diese summe entspricht einem drittel des
gesamten eu-haushaltes damit ließe sich
prächtig der kampf gegen den klimawandel
angehen dazu jochen flasbarth vom
bundesumweltministerium das von der spd
geführt wird
die landwirtschaft hat jetzt die chance
sich für eine transformation zu öffnen
und das kann man politisch flankieren
in dem die ganz auf die honorierung
gesellschaftlicher leistungen die umwelt
klima und tierschutz ausgerichtet wird
der klimaschutz aktivistin von samson
engagiert sich bei feindes für future
und bezeichnet gab als zitat eine klima
entscheidung wahrscheinlich eine der
größten des jahrzehnts und so sind die
erwartungen extrem groß da deutschland
die ratspräsidentschaft innehat haben
die bundesregierung und julia klöckner
die bundesministerin für ernährung
landwirtschaft und verbraucherschutz die
einmalige chance bewegung in die ganze
sache zu bringen und die verhandlung
positiv zu beeinflussen
doch klöckner ist der ansicht dass die
zitat gemeinsame agrarpolitik eine
politik für landwirte sei
sie bezeichnet die
landwirtschaftspolitik als eine zitat
wirtschaftspolitik für bauern und
bäuerinnen in einer bedarfsanalyse die
das landwirtschaftsministerium erstellt
hat soll der landwirtschaftssektor etwa
11,8 millionen tonnen co2 äquivalente
jährlich bis zum jahr 2030 einsparen wie
genau das gehen soll davon kein wort
aber immerhin werden die klimapläne
jetzt erwähnt in einer teureren version
dafür sind die gar nicht vorgekommen das
muss man sich mal vorstellen
das sagt wirklich viel der
naturschutzbund deutschland nabu
schreibt dazu auf seiner webseite viel
geld für die intensive landwirtschaft
wenig naturschutz so lässt sich die eu
agrarpolitik der letzten jahrzehnte
zusammen fassen
mit der neuen förderperiode 2000
21 bis 2027 muss sich dies endlich
ändern denn das rasante vogel und
insekten sterben und die sich
verschärfende klimakrise lassen keinen
aufschub zu der naturschutzbund
deutschland hat drei konkrete
forderungen punkt eins mehr platz für
artenvielfalt um vögel und insekten zu
retten brauchen diese tiere platz und
zwar in form von hecken blühflächen oder
mehrjährigen brachen mindestens zehn
prozent ihrer fläche sollten die
agrarbetriebe im rahmen der neuen
förderpolitik nicht bewirtschaften
sondern der natur überlassen diese
maßnahme so genannte grüne infrastruktur
zu schaffen hätte für die landwirtschaft
sogar einen positiven effekt denn
dadurch würde nicht nur die
bestäubungsleistung der insekten zu
nehmen auch weniger böden würden so
durch wind und wasser erosion verloren
gehen wissenschaftliche studien zeigen
dass solche maßnahmen tatsächlich in
großem ausmaß zum artenschutz beitragen
eine norwegische studie hat in diesem
jahr gezeigt dass solche
artenschutzprojekte funktionieren
demnach kann beispielsweise das
vogelsterben durch bestimmte maßnahmen
eingedämmt werden auch die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sprachen sich dafür aus mindestens zehn
prozent der landwirtschaftsflächen zur
ökologischen vorrangflächen umzuwandeln
im wald sollten fünf prozent der fläche
völlig nutzungs frei bleiben die
aussterberate könnte dadurch um knapp 40
prozent verringert werden
das forschungsteam aus so appelliert das
zeitnah gehandelt werden muss der
datenschutz dürfe nicht erst angegangen
werden wenn eine art bereits fast
ausgestorben ist
punkt zwei europas landwirtinnen und
landwirte sollten für naturschutz
leistung belohnt werden der nabu fordert
dass landwirtinnen und landwirte geld
damit verdienen sollten wenn sie mehr
für die natur tun als es die gesetze
vorschreiben
punkt 3 der umbau der landwirtschaft
soll gefördert werden betriebs und
vermarktungskonzepte müssen umgestellt
werden damit die landwirtschaft der
zukunft naturverträglich und
klimaneutral gestaltet werden kann
landwirtinnen und landwirte sollen von
der eu investitionshilfen für diese
maßnahmen bekommt umso mit steigenden
umweltauflagen klarzukommen und
gleichzeitig auch bessere preise für
ihre produkte zu bekommen klar ist
jedenfalls für alle das potenzial
landwirtschaftlichen klimaschutz zu
betreiben ist riesig bereits vor zwei
jahren hatte die eu kommission einen
ersten vorschlag eingereicht wie eine
gab reform gestaltet werden könnte
der plan sieht unter anderem sogenannte
öko regelungen vor demnach sollen
landwirtinnen und landwirte zusätzliches
geld bekommen wenn sie mit ihren
betrieben freiwillige umweltprogramme
umsätzen zudem setzt dieser vorschlag
von 2018 weiterhin auf die sogenannten
flächenprämie heißt also soviel je mehr
hektar und land bewirtschaftet wird umso
mehr geld fließt in das portemonnaie der
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe und genau
hier setzt die kritik an
denn dieses system belohnt landwirtinnen
und landwirte die viel land nutzen ohne
dabei aber viel für die umwelt zu tun
verteilungspolitisch sei diese flächen
bremen nicht zu rechtfertigen so die
kritik bernhard osterburg von thünen
institut in einem spiegel interview dass
dem landwirtschaftsministerium
zugeordnet ist faktisch werden mit der
flächen förderung landwirte belohnt wenn
sie die bisherige landnutzung fortführen
landwirtschaft auf entwässerten
moorböden ist aber sehr klimaschädlich
kritik kommt auch vom europäischen
rechnungshof demnach geht die
eu-kommission von unrealistischen
klimaschutz wirkungen aus und es mangele
an klaren und nachvollziehbaren zielen
auch der wissenschafts community gehen
die reformpläne der europäischen
kommission nicht weit genug in einem
papier das mehr als 3600 forscherinnen
und forscher unterschrieben haben heißt
es der vorschlag der europäischen
kommission für den zeitraum nach 2020
geht nur unzureichend auf umweltprobleme
und auf herausforderungen der
nachhaltigkeit ein und führt mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit zu einem business as
usual szenario also weitermachen wie
bisher
eine landwirtschaft die komplett
treibhausgas frei ist ist unrealistisch
das ist klar
doch bis 2050 möchte die eu weitgehend
klimaneutral sein und dazu muss auch die
landwirtschaft einen teil beitragen doch
die landwirtinnen und landwirte haben
eine große lobby der deutsche
bauernverband hat den klimaschutz
angeblich im blick doch zu großen
kompromissen ist man hier nicht bereit
den tierbestand könne man nicht deutlich
reduzieren und auch strengere auflagen
für die flächenprämien heißt man hier
nicht gut 15 bis 20 prozent der
verfügbaren mittel könnten für öko
regelungen genutzt werden so die
vorstellungen des deutschen
bauernverbandes umweltverbände wie
beispielsweise der nabu wwf oder bnd
fordern mindestens 30 prozent wenn die
europäische union dann irgendwann mal
sich einigen sollte steht eine weitere
entscheidung aus nämlich
der einzelnen mitgliedsstaaten die nach
plan der eu-kommission größere
spielräume haben sollen kritiker
fürchten dass dann eu-weit eine
konkurrenz um die geringsten auflagen
entsteht festhalten lässt sich also die
reform der gemeinsamen agrarpolitik der
eu
die größte chance in diesem jahrzehnt
sein könnte um die landwirtschaft zu
verändern um sie umweltverträglich und
klimafreundlicher zu machen und das
unter europaweit fairen
wettbewerbsbedingungen eine veränderung
die längst überfällig ist und außerdem
ein baustein um die klimakrise anzugehen
und zu bekämpfen
es gibt übrigens noch ganz andere
lösungsansätze warum ist das eigentlich
landwirtschaft ein denkansatz in eine
ganz andere richtung liefere ich in
meinem buch per aufzug in den weltraum
das am 14 oktober erscheinen wird also
hier vorbestellen und es wird ein event
in berlin geben wo ich einen tag lang
jedem der oder die kommt eine widmung in
sein buch schreiben werde
und schreibt in die kommentare in welche
städte ich noch kommen soll
also ich freue mich auf euch bis dann
bleibt dran